[Music]
girl in the dragon tattoo is based on
the books by steve larsen and in those
books your character elizabeth is a
redhead but you guys didn't go that way
in the movie so much well no she's a
redhead but she dyes her hair black
right yes which is yeah it was very
important to me because i
was a follower of the books you wanted
to be true to the books yes but
obviously there's no way to really
depict that in a movie except that um i
had to wear merkin do you know what a
merkin is
andy knows i know what american is
uh oh yeah i do know what american is
american is kind of a wig for for down
below yes it's a it's a wig for your
lady bits
this interview's over
uh
so
you wore one of those for that movie
yeah i mean they didn't they didn't ask
me to but i'm naked so much in it i
wanted one because it felt like a little
fur bikini
but i
i
i'm feeling like such a perv now
tell me more about the fur bikini
uh michael's really cute it was a cute
little for bikini and i had them make it
strawberry blonde oh
okay uh
is that something that you that you give
that back when you're done or do you no
i have it you have it okay
okay that's good you want to keep that
a lot of creeps on ebay you know
i know um
yeah uh you were very uh
oh shut up
leave me alone
they always pick on me